Les métiers liés à la montagne
font partie des métiers les plus risqués.
Parmi eux, le métier de cordiste.
Les accidents sont rares, mais
s'ils ont lieu, ils sont souvent mortels.
On déplore une vingtaine
de décès par an en France.
Le métier de guide de haute montagne
fait face à plus d'accidents,
pas toujours fatals
mais toujours dramatiques.
Sébastien Bonjean est cordiste
depuis que le métier est reconnu.
Il s'y connaît bien,
mais doit s'adapter à de nouvelles tâches.
Vous avez une corde en plus ?
Quand je me suis retourné,
j'étais seul.
Il y a eu une chute pour une raison
que je ne peux pas expliquer.
Gérard Ottavio est président
du bureau des guides de Valtournenche.
Il a perdu l'un des siens
l'année dernière.
Les clients, eux, ont survécu.
Elle n'a pas réussi à se sauver
et nous l'avons perdue.
Sébastien et Gérard, au travail,
jouent tous les jours avec le vide,
un milieu à risque
qui les oblige à bien s'assurer.
C'est génial.
Nous sommes au début de l'été
et pour Sébastien, c'est la reprise.
Comme beaucoup de cordistes,
Sébastien est saisonnier.
L'hiver, il travaille
dans une station de ski.
L'été, il fait des travaux sur corde
pour une entreprise spécialisée.
Aujourd'hui, pour sa première journée,
il va aider l'équipe d'un beau chantier.
On l'a missionné pour apporter un outil
indispensable à l'avancée des travaux.
C'est un vérin, il y a un trépied,
il y a un manomètre.
C'est mon outil.
C'est l'outil, en général,
du chef de chantier
qui va vérifier
les ancrages de son chantier.
Une opération bénigne à terre
mais plus compliquée à exécuter
à plusieurs mètres du sol.
Pendu à une corde,
l'opération est périlleuse.
Sébastien est cordiste
depuis environ 10 ans,
c'est un métier plutôt récent,
reconnu par un code depuis 2008.
Cordiste, c'est plutôt une manière
de travailler en sécurité,
de se déplacer sur corde
et d'accéder à des sites
d'accès difficile,
des falaises, des dessous de toits,
des dessous de ponts,
tout ce qui est inaccessible
avec des échelles ou des nacelles.
La corde est vraiment un aspect
de sécurité et de déplacement,
un moyen d'accès au chantier.
Aujourd'hui, Sébastien se rend en Italie
via le tunnel du Mont-Blanc.
Il est attendu par Richard,
son chef de chantier.
Rendez-vous de l'autre côté du tunnel,
car l'accès au site
est plus court par l'Italie.
- Bonjour Richard.
- T'as le matos ?
- J’ai le vérin, oui.
- Oui !
Aujourd'hui,
c'est l'héliportage de matériaux,
une aubaine pour Sébastien, qui va
s'en servir pour aller sur le chantier.
C'est sympa pour aller au boulot.
Il y a pire.
Sébastien se rend sur un lieu de travail
à près de 3 400 mètres d'altitude.
Un chantier sur le toit de l'Europe.
C'est là le chantier ?
- Oui.
Ce chantier est destiné
à renforcer le soubassement
de l'arrivée du fameux télécabine
de la traversée des glaciers.
Monsieur, ça va ?
- Ça va et toi ?
- Nickel.
Là, on va mettre le baudrier,
le harnais de sécurité,
avec des bretelles.
Sébastien va mettre
10 minutes à s'équiper.
Son protocole de sécurité
est très stricte.
C'est notre compagnon de sécurité,
un petit chariot qui va être placé
sur une deuxième corde de sécurité,
qui va nous suivre
quand on monte, quand on descend.
Il coulisse et en cas de chute,
pour une raison x ou y,
ce chariot va
automatiquement bloquer.
C'est une sécurité
supplémentaire et obligatoire.
Tu as des gants, des lunettes ?
- Oui.
Il faut faire attention à tout
quand vous descendez sur corde,
aux alentours, à l'environnement.
On n'est pas
à l'abri que ça casse.
Puis, surtout, c'est notre vie.
On est obligés
d'être prudents par rapport à ça
et dès que c'est abîmé,
il faut changer.
Après,
on va aller chercher le vérin.
C'est l'accès au chantier ?
- Voilà, l'accès au chantier.
Il faut faire bien attention.
Le travail sur corde
commence ici pour Sébastien.
À partir de maintenant,
aucune faute de sécurité ne sera tolérée.
Une belle journée d'automne commence
dans la vallée la plus réputée d'Italie.
Gérard a rendez-vous avec un client
pour profiter de cette météo clémente
et l'entraîner à gravir l'un des sommets
les plus mythiques des Alpes.
Nous allons faire
une via ferrata avec un ami à moi,
qui désire vraiment
un jour escalade le Cervin.
En montagne, les clients
restent assez rarement de simples clients.
C'est une question de rapprochement
créé par un environnement
et une aventure exceptionnelle.
Le rapport qui se crée
après avoir été un peu en montagne
devient automatiquement
un rapport d'amitié
parce que partir en montagne
crée forcément du lien.
Au-delà du fait d'être lié par une corde,
souvent, presque tout le temps,
ça dépend de ce qu'on va faire,
mais il s'instaure vraiment un rapport
de confiance qui est réciproque.
Avant l'ascension,
Gérard montre à Marco l'itinéraire.
La falaise est très verticale,
c'est l'endroit parfait
pour appréhender le vide.
Avant de débuter une ascension
aussi difficile que le Cervin,
Gérard veut que Marco soit à l'aise
dans les manœuvres de corde
et sera capable de bien réagir
en cas de problème.
Car dans une ascension sur corde,
la vie du guide
dépend aussi de son client.
C'est très important aussi
car c'est une première journée d'approche
avec un test
sur la via ferrata,
qui permet de commencer
à nous comprendre, moi et le client,
et nous commençons
à trouver cette symbiose.
Il y a la gestion de la corde entre nous
et même sur une voie
de montagne classique,
on a déjà essayé la cordée
et ça, c'est une bonne chose.
Nous venons ici, car on dit
que c'est très exposé et très vertical
alors nous allons tester ma résistance.
J'utilise ça pour la corde :
je mets la corde à l'intérieur
et tu dois seulement l'enlever
quand j'ai mis le prochain.
Entre temps, même si tu traverses,
tu mets une longe.
comme ça, même si tu glissais,
tu resterais quand même attaché.
Avant de partir, j'attends toujours
que tu passes la corde dans l'autre.
Les dernières consignes transmises
et c'est parti
pour une ascension de trois heures.
Trois heures durant lesquelles
il faudra garder une vigilance permanente.
Là, c'est une partie
où la roche est glissante
à cause des passages répétés.
Après la partie très glissante,
Gérard et Marco vont en attaquer
une particulièrement verticale.
C'est le plus dangereux
et c'est dans ces moments-là
que la corde est indispensable.
La via ferrata en elle-même,
faite de manière classique,
a toujours un risque.
Le risque peut même être très élevé,
car ce qu'on appelle
le facteur de chute est très élevé.
On s'arrête, certes,
on ne chute pas jusqu'en bas,
mais plus on est loin du point d'arrêt
plus on risque justement de se blesser
à cause du choc brutal
que l'on subit en chutant.
C'est le plus gros risque qui existe.
Sans corde, en cas de chute,
Marco ne serait retenu que par sa longe
mais elle ne le retiendrait
qu'après plusieurs mètres de chute,
ce qui pourrait le blesser grièvement.
Sébastien s'apprête
à descendre sur corde.
Sa mission : tester
le premier forage d'ancrage.
Il ne doit jamais se déplacer
sans doubler toutes ses sécurités.
J'ai placé mon descendeur,
dans lequel je vais faire une clé,
le verrouiller le temps de le délonger.
Il y a toujours une appréhension,
mais elle passe très vite.
On arrive avec l'expérience,
on va vite évaluer les risques
sur un chantier ici, qui est très confiné,
c'est une petite zone,
Chose importante,
ce petit nœud au bout de la corde,
ce n'est pas un hasard,
c'est un nœud d'arrêt.
Si jamais, pour une raison x ou y,
il arrivait qu'un appareil de descente
ou de montée glisse sur la corde,
le nœud nous arrête et
évite d'aller au bout et de finir en bas.
Là, il doit y avoir 50 mètres.
On part en arrière,
on va jusqu'en bas.
Dans une pente à plus de 25 degrés,
si une chute ne se rattrape pas
dans le premier mètre, c'est trop tard.
L'objectif du chantier est de consolider
le soubassement du bâtiment.
Il accueille les touristes
à l'arrivée des télécabines.
Il faut re-solidariser
les roches entre elles.
La technique est de les ancrer ensemble
grâce à des tiges d'acier
qui pénètrent à cinq mètres de profondeur.
Ces tiges doivent résister à 28 tonnes.
L'opération est titanesque.
Il faut mettre en place,
grâce à des cordes,
une foreuse en pleine paroi,
de plus de 1500 kilos
et la déplacer à la main.
Les risques d'un tel chantier
n'expose pas que les cordistes.
Cinquante mètres plus bas, des randonneurs
sont entrés dans un périmètre dangereux.
Ils sont sortis du chemin et risquent
de se prendre des pierres sur la tête.
Ne restez pas en bas !
Ne restez pas là !
Le vérin qu'a apporté ce matin Sébastien
va exercer par pression le poids
de 28 tonnes sur les tiges d'acier.
L'opération est obligatoire.
Toutes les tiges vont être testées
et un rapport de conformité
devra être fourni aux autorités.
Suspendu à une corde,
la manipulation est difficile.
On a dû s'y reprendre à trois fois.
parce que le terrain s'est tassé,
comme tu peux le voir.
Le terrain est descendu.
Plutôt que de tirer sur la barre,
le terrain descend donc c'est faussé.
Donc, on a dû repartir à zéro,
re-sceller le vérin pour repartir
sur quelque chose de stable.
Donc, là, en l'occurrence
on est à 10 tonnes, Richard, c'est ça ?
On a tiré 10 tonnes et la barre
a bougé de 0,02 millimètres,
donc rien du tout.
Pour le moment,
on est tout à fait sereins.
On doit aller à 28 tonnes,
ça devrait aller, on n'a pas bougé.
Ça va mettre en pression et on lâchera.
Ça se fait en plusieurs fois.
Tu peux faire en restant longé,
en me laissant une corde 10 minutes ?
Vue panoramique.
Sébastien va passer
une semaine sur le chantier.
Souvent, les cordistes sont
en grand déplacement, loin de chez eux.
Pour plus de confort et de solidarité,
ils se retrouvent dans un même logement
et partagent les mêmes repas.
Une bonne occasion pour chacun
de raconter ses expériences.
On a eu peur.
Un rappel qui descend
plus vite que prévu,
ou des choses qui se passent très bien,
et qu'avec un peu de recul,
on se dit qu'on n’aurait pas dû faire ça,
c'était tendu.
On a beau être vigilant et expérimenté,
l'erreur est humaine.
Ça, j'avais fait un rappel italien
et je ne savais plus
sur quelle corde remonter.
Je suis arrivé en haut, heureusement,
j'étais monté sur les deux cordes
j'étais monté sur la mauvaise
et tout le long, j'ai eu bien peur.
Les statistiques
en travaux sur corde,
il y a très peu d'accident
mais ils sont fatals.
On en a eu l'expérience aussi avec Seb.
Il y a quelques années,
Sébastien a lui-même vécu
une histoire dramatique dans son métier.
C'était un chantier
dans le Val-de-Fier, dans l'Ain.
On était deux et puis,
j'étais occupé à faire une manipulation
de déplacement d'une machine de forage.
Quand je me suis retourné, j'étais seul.
Il y a eu une chute pour une raison
que je n'ai pas encore pu expliquer
que personne n'a pu expliquer,
vu qu'il n'y avait personne d'autre.
Un accident, un tragique accident.
Gérard et Marco vont franchir
le passage le plus dur de la via ferrata.
Il est déversant
et nécessite la force de ses bras.
Gérard briefe Marco
pour éviter les mauvaises surprises.
Un petit conseil :
essaye de te tourner
un peu sur le côté.
Si tu tournes en faisant mouvement,
que tu utilises le bras en fermeture,
tu te fatigues moins en montant.
Je monte en premier,
une fois là-haut, je te dis de venir,
tu y vas et je t'assure toujours.
Après le passage le plus difficile,
c'est le plus impressionnant,
celui du pont de singe.
À peine arrivé,
c'est à Marco de se présenter.
Les pas doivent être précis
et assurés sur le câble d'acier
suspendu en haut du vide.
Je pensais que
ça aurait été plus difficile,
mais c'est très excitant.
C'est différent,
car c'est un câble en métal.
Les derniers pas sont proches
et sur une vue magnifique du Mont Cervin,
Gérard passe sa corde
dans le dernier anneau.
Les deux hommes sont heureux,
ils ont réussi leur voie avec succès
mais la journée n'est pas finie pour eux.
Gérard veut maintenant mettre Marco
dans un environnement plus difficile.
On va faire encore un peu d'escalade
mais sur une partie un peu plus technique.
En fait, pour faire le Cervin,
ce qu'il faudrait,
c'est faire quelques sorties
plus en situation, plus en montagne,
en haute montagne où il y a de l'altitude
et progresser petit à petit,
un pas après l'autre
jusqu'à pouvoir faire
l'ascension du Cervin.
Bravo, tu pourrais passer
plus à ta gauche.
C'est plus simple, Marco.
Nous faisons déjà
de l'escalade sportive,
on appelle ça comme ça,
et c'est une étape indispensable,
car on est toujours en sécurité,
bien sûr, avec la corde,
mais le terrain
permet d'être un peu plus technique.
On apprend à escalader,
à se positionner correctement,
mais toujours en sécurité.
À cette hauteur,
on ne peut pas grimper sans corde.
Ça deviendrait beaucoup trop risqué.
L'avantage de prendre un guide
quand on est client
est qu'il est en premier de cordée,
il ouvre la voie
et prend les plus grands risques de chute.
Pour le second,
les risques sont minimes
car en cas de chute,
il est tout de suite retenu par la corde.
C'est beaucoup plus simple,
beaucoup plus serein pour le mental.
Il y a la corde là-haut
et avec, tout est plus facile.
C'est maintenant à Marco
de terminer la voie.
Gérard n'est pas passé par le plus facile,
mais c'est volontaire.
Comme ça, il rencontre
un peu de difficultés.
Il devra se débrouiller
pour réussir à passer,
à bien utiliser les pieds.
Marco, c'est quand tu veux.
Pour Marco,
la partie ne sera pas simple,
mais grâce à Gérard,
il a confiance,
et ça, c'est particulièrement important
pour sa future course en montagne.
Ici, la difficulté
est plus élevée que sur le Cervin.
Il sera donc bien préparé.
C'est maintenant
le temps de la redescente.
Là encore, il va falloir
faire entièrement confiance à son guide
pour se laisser suspendre dans le vide
au bout d'une simple corde
Sur le chantier d'Helbronner,
les cordistes sont déjà à l'œuvre.
Aujourd'hui, l'équipe va projeter du béton
pour consolider la structure en surface.
Le béton est armé de pièces métalliques
pour renforcer la matière
et est envoyé sous haute pression
dans les tuyaux.
Au bout, la lance est tenue à la main.
L'opération est périlleuse,
car tout va se faire sur corde.
Pour la première fois, Sébastien
participera à ce genre d'opération.
C'est ça le métier de cordiste,
savoir tout faire pendu à une corde.
Pas question pour Sébastien
de tenir la lance.
Cela demande une expérience préalable.
Ça, c'est le rôle de Richard.
Sébastien, lui,
va simplement tenir le tuyau
pour l’aider dans sa manœuvre.
Ce qu'il ne faut surtout pas,
c'est que le tuyau se pince,
parce que sinon, à l'ouverture,
Richard va décoller.
Ce poste est difficile à tenir.
Pour l'aider, Max va se tenir en retrait
et lui indiquer les gestes
à faire pour la sécurité de Richard,
et pour la sienne.
Si la lance est lâchée,
c'est la catastrophe.
Elle sera incontrôlable
et ça sera l'accident assuré.
Max en a déjà fait les frais.
Ça m'est arrivé
à l'Aiguille du Midi, une erreur humaine.
J'ai ouvert la vanne sans le vouloir,
j'ai pris le tuyau dans le visage,
et ça m'a cassé le nez.
Rien de grave, c'était net,
le lendemain, je travaillais.
L'hôpital m'a soigné.
Même en ayant l'habitude,
il faut rester vigilant.
Il faut aussi être conscient,
comme d'autres métiers,
que le risque zéro n'existe pas
et qu'il peut arriver quelque chose.
Il ne faut pas ignorer ça
ni en faire abstraction.
Le métier de cordiste combine les dangers
du déplacement sur corde,
et ceux liés aux travaux du bâtiment.
On peut même dire
que le mélange des deux est explosif.
Chaque incident
peut être source d'accident.
Oui, Ben, je t'écoute.
On vient d'avoir les compresseurs
qui s'arrêtent, on fait quoi ?
Arrêtez le béton !
Arrête-le, s'il te plaît.
Ferme la vanne.
Il a l'air de chauffer.
Écoute le bruit qu'il fait
en essayant de démarrer.
Je vais appeler le mécano quand même,
ça va dépasser mes compétences.
Il faut toujours faire
très attention au tuyau d'air.
Ils ont des sécurités pour ça.
Il y a neuf bars à l'intérieur,
si un tuyau se décroche en passant,
ou une erreur de manipulation,
on peut la prendre sur nous.
Les blessures comme ça,
c'est l'erreur bête qui arrive vite.
Il faut faire attention.
Mais le compresseur ne veut rien savoir,
impossible de le redémarrer.
Pour aujourd'hui,
toute l'équipe est bloquée.
Il faut être ordonné,
car il y a une multitude de cordes,
il y a des câbles, des lignes d'air.
Si on commence
à tout mettre dans le désordre,
que chaque matin,
on met une demi-heure à défaire les nœuds
et les cordes, on n'avance plus.
C'est accidentogène, car on ne sait plus
sur quoi on est pendus, accrochés,
c'est comme ça
qu'on se trompe, là, c'est rangé.
On sait que celle-là
est prête à l'emploi.
C'est replié, on n'en parle plus.
C'est un gain de temps.
On préserve le matériel,
surtout celui qui sert à notre sécurité.
C'est important.
L'hiver est précoce
dans la Vallée d'Aoste.
Nous sommes à peine en automne
et il neige déjà abondamment.
Pour Gérard, plus possible
d'emmener qui que ce soit en montagne.
C'est sûr, il faut savoir renoncer,
changer de sortie ou faire autre chose.
C'est certain.
Il faut vraiment prendre des décisions
en toute sérénité
et dire non,
aujourd'hui, on ne fait rien, on renonce.
On essaiera une autre fois.
Ça fait partie de l'alpinisme.
Marco vient alors rendre son matériel.
L'escalade, c'est fini pour la saison.
Une décision qu'il accepte sans regret.
De toute façon, la montagne est là,
personne ne va la déplacer.
La prudence doit toujours rester de mise
quand on est un alpiniste,
et encore plus un guide.
Gérard le sait mieux que quiconque.
Il a perdu une collègue
l'année dernière.
Simona Hosquet
était guide depuis quatre ans.
Elle s'est faite emporter à peine 30 ans.
Ça, c'est le livre
sur l'histoire des guides du Cervin
Là, c'est un texte
tiré du carnet intime de Simona
dans lequel elle écrit :
J'ai choisi l'alpinisme
car on est seul face à soi-même,
pour faire le vide à chaque pas accompli,
être libre, à chaque instant.
Je sais que je risque beaucoup
en suivant mes passions,
en allant à la recherche de moi-même,
de mes émotions,
pour comprendre qui je suis.
Pour découvrir mon âme
et la sentir vibrer.
Ça s'est passé en hiver.
C'était l'un de nos guides,
la seule guide femme.
La première à faire partie de l'histoire
de la société des guides du Cervin.
Elle s'appelait Simona Hosquet,
une guide très compétente
et alpiniste, aussi.
Malheureusement,
elle est décédée sous une avalanche
durant une sortie hors-piste
avec des clients.
Les clients, eux, ont survécu
mais elle n'a pas réussi
à se sauver et nous l'avons perdu.
Le métier de guide est tragiquement lié
avec la mort en montagne.
Chacun en a bien conscience
et vit avec les décès de ses collègues.
C'est une réalité
avec laquelle tu vis toujours.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'il y a des accidents
qu'on va s'arrêter de partir en montagne.
On va de l'avant même si ça reste
une cicatrice pour toujours.
Je pense souvent à elle.
Je pense aux projets
qu'on avait ensemble.
J'ai fait des sorties en montagne
avec elle.
Rien d'extraordinaire, mais je me souviens
qu'elle était passionnée par la montagne.
Sans cette passion, il serait impossible
pour les guides de repartir en montagne.
C'est toute l'histoire
de l'alpinisme qui le montre.
À l'étage du bureau des guides,
un petit musée est consacré au Cervin
et, là encore,
son histoire s'est écrite dans le sang.
En plus d'être
la première ascension du Cervin
et la réussite de l'escalade
d'une montagne considérée inaccessible,
C'est aussi
le premier drame de l’alpinisme.
Durant l'ascension,
puis durant la descente,
quatre personnes
de la cordée Whymper vont mourir.
C'était les premiers alpinistes du Cervin.
Aujourd'hui, chaque guide a conscience
que la mort est un des risques du métier
car, souvent,
la chute en haute montagne est fatale.
Je sais qu'un jour,
je pourrais ne pas rentrer.
Ma femme le sait.
Mes enfants sont trop jeunes,
ils ne peuvent pas encore comprendre.
Si mon fils voulait suivre ce chemin,
je lui dirais d'être vraiment prudent,
mais je ne pourrais pas lui dire
de ne pas le faire.
Les chantiers en travaux acrobatiques
sont toujours à risque.
Même si les cordistes sont aguerris
au protocole de sécurité,
il est toujours important
de la garantir au maximum.
Julien Baud est le patron
de la société ACRO BTP.
Cordiste de formation,
il connaît les risques du métier
et s'assure de sa bonne mise en œuvre.
C'est important
de faire un tour des chantiers
pour veiller un petit peu
l'aspect sécuritaire,
car ils ont une pression
de productivité régulière
et en même temps,
il faut les protéger.
Nous sommes dans les Alpes-Maritimes,
dans les Gorges de la Mescla.
Le chantier de Julien
est vraiment isolé, en pleine paroi.
Son rôle est de retenir
les pierres d'un éboulis.
Elles peuvent à tout moment,
chuter de 150 mètres
sur une zone
d'exploitation hydraulique en contrebas.
Mais le lieu est particulièrement meuble
et les accidents fréquents.
Il y a eu pas mal
d'accidents dernièrement.
Ça fait des années
qu'ils font des travaux.
Dès le début, le mot d'ordre
était clairement : pas de blessé.
Comme d'habitude,
on fait attention au personnel,
mais particulièrement
sur un chantier accidentogène.
On va descendre,
mettez-vous à l'abri !
La chute des pierres
est le risque majeur pour les cordistes,
avec la glissade et la chute.
Je ne sais pas s'il a bien mis la bavette,
on ne va pas aller lui remplir.
Il y a quand même du danger.
Oui, quand même.
Il y a une bonne marge de 150 mètres,
mais il y a également
une petite barrière provisoire à l'aval.
On reste dans
un milieu austère de cordiste.
Les ouvriers utilisent leur technique
de progression sur corde pour y accéder.
Ils tiennent debout sur place,
mais le danger peut arriver
à tout moment, de n'importe où.
Se balader là-dedans,
c'est vraiment une rivière de cailloux.
Les terrasses nous aident.
Au départ, c'est ça.
Après, il y a la zone en bas
avec 100 ou 150 mètres plein vide.
C'est quoi sur ton casque ?
Mon prénom et mon groupe sanguin.
Dans un souci de réactivité,
s'il y a un accident,
les informations sont sur le casque.
Attention à toi.
Après, c'est le risque naturel
qui va rentrer en jeu,
mais techniquement,
on fait tout pour éviter un drame.
Visiblement, Julien est rassuré,
la sécurité sur le chantier est respectée.
Son inspection est satisfaisante.
Le but du jeu,
c'est d'avoir nos gars en sécurité
et de viser le risque zéro.
Retour avec Gérard,
il se prépare à un événement
qui a lieu tous les deux ans.
Alors, pour l'occasion
il va se mettre sur son 31.
Nous avons un rassemblement
des membres du club des amis du Cervin.
En font partie,
ceux qui ont escaladé le Cervin
avec un guide de notre association.
Direction Valtournenche,
à la salle des fêtes du village.
Le héros du jour, le Mont Cervin.
Au programme : projection de film
et hommage aux pionniers italiens
de l'ascension.
Bonjour et bienvenue à vous tous.
Premier hommage
à Jean-Antoine Carrel,
premier guide à avoir réalisé
l'ascension du Cervin côté italien,
mythe fondateur
du bureau des guides.
Sa vie se termine tragiquement
sur les pentes mêmes du Cervin.
Il y est décédé d'épuisement en 1890,
en redescendant du sommet
après plusieurs enchaînements.
Il est question de remplacer
la croix à l'endroit de son décès
pour ne jamais oublier.
La tradition en Italie
est quelque chose de fondateur.
Elle montre ici le respect
pour le métier de guide.
Pour moi, c'est très important
car ça fait partie de la tradition.
Guido Monzino a créé ce club
avec justement l'idée de se retrouver.
Je suis fière de lui, de ce qu'il fait,
mais, comme je disais tout à l'heure,
c'est un métier plutôt dangereux.
Quand il part,
il y a toujours un peu de peur.
Lorsqu'il revient, par contre,
il y a la magie du retour
et la joie d'être ensemble.
Pour bien clôturer la fête,
les amis du Cervin
vont se retrouver à table
le reste de l'après-midi.
Les Italiens festoient en grande pompe.
Je vous présente mon ami Hervé Barmasse,
guide alpin du Cervin et alpiniste.
- On est amis.
- Amis, oui.
Il est le guide
du bureau de la Vallée d'Aoste
le plus doué de sa génération.
Hervé a réalisé de nouvelles voies
sur le Cervin, avec son père,
lui aussi guide de la Vallée d'Aoste.
Puis il a enchaîné avec des solitaires,
la façon la plus difficile
et surtout la plus risquée
de réaliser des itinéraires en montagne.
Le secret d'un alpiniste,
si on regarde ceux
qui ont réussi à vieillir,
comme Bonatti, Messner et d'autres,
est toujours dans le fait de comprendre
quand tu peux dépasser tes limites
sans risquer ta vie
et de le faire le moins possible.
En t'exposant à des risques importants
à la montagne, des risques trop grands,
tout n'est jamais sous contrôle,
un accident peut se produire
d'un moment à l'autre.
En tant qu'alpiniste, j'ai déjà
pris des risques et eu très peur.
Hervé s'est retrouvé au Pakistan
en tant qu'instructeur pour guides locaux.
Lors d'une ascension
d'une cascade de glace,
tout a failli basculer.
Par miracle, l'avalanche a eu lieu
au milieu de la cascade de glace,
alors qu'il avait décidé d'ouvrir
un itinéraire complètement sur la gauche,
une décision qui lui a sauvé la vie.
Hervé !
Ça va ?
Il va bien.
Je pense qu'on a eu de la chance.
À une heure près,
on était tous morts.
Pour moi, ça s'est bien passé,
mais je connais beaucoup de gens
dont des amis qui, malheureusement,
sont décédés à la montagne.
Aujourd'hui, Sébastien a été
mandaté par son patron
pour prêter main-forte
sur un autre chantier.
Il ne va pas être déçu,
c'est le plus haut d'Europe,
sur l'Aiguille du Midi elle-même,
à 3842 mètres d'altitude.
Un nouveau chantier
et de nouveaux cordistes l'attendent.
On se connaît depuis longtemps.
Ça fait combien de temps ?
À peu près 13 minutes.
Treize minutes !
C'est le principe du métier.
On a la même couleur,
donc ça, c'est bon.
C'est le principe du métier, oui.
C'est-à-dire ?
Découvrir de nouvelles têtes souvent.
Puis découvrir des endroits.
Des endroits assez sympa en général.
En l'occurrence,
celui-là va être plus que sympa.
Pour accéder au sommet,
ils empruntent un ascenseur de chantier,
un privilège, car aucun touriste
ne peut accéder à cet endroit magique
du sommet de l'Aiguille du Midi.
Le site est encore interdit au public.
Je n'ai jamais vu ça en vrai.
Aujourd'hui,
Sébastien va faire équipe avec Anne,
une alpiniste qui a fait partie
de l'équipe de France d'alpinisme.
Leur mission du jour :
nettoyer les parois vitrées
du Pas dans le Vide
qui doit bientôt rouvrir.
C'est pendus à 3 842 mètres
qu'ils vont devoir œuvrer.
À cette hauteur,
il vaut mieux être bien accroché.
Évidemment, on verrouille toujours.
Qu'il y ait 10 mètres ou 1 000 mètres,
il ne faut pas tomber.
C'est pareil,
c'est la même vigilance.
C'est le boulot, c'est le quotidien.
Ces deux cordes.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'on est plus haut
qu'on s'assure plus.
Après avoir aidé à projeter
du ciment en paroi,
voilà Sébastien,
simple laveur de vitres.
Il faut savoir tout faire,
on voit que cordiste n'est pas un métier.
Ça résume bien,
la corde est un moyen d'accès.
Je ne suis pas d'accord.
Non, sinon, un guide, il est quoi ?
Il se balade, il est sur corde.
La manipulation des cordes.
Je m'exprime mal.
Comme je disais mardi,
on peut être cordiste maçon,
cordiste charpentier, laveur de vitres,
- C'est de la polyvalence.
- Oui, je me suis mal exprimé.
Anne m'a repris très justement.
Ça fait partie du métier.
Je ne suis pas d'accord avec ceux
qui disent que ce n'est pas un métier.
Ce qu'il faut,
c'est réussir à joindre les deux.
C'est ça qui est compliqué.
Le métier de cordiste est en effet
un métier à part entière.
Depuis quelques années, il est reconnu.
Pour le pratiquer,
il faut un certificat de qualification
professionnelle de cordiste.
C'est très important,
il faut tout attacher.
En sachant que, sous nous,
il y a une passerelle,
où, en ce moment,
passent environ 4 000 personnes par jour.
Donc, il ne faut rien laisser tomber
et on travaille sans filet.
Anne et Sébastien
ont préparé leur amarrage
en vérifiant scrupuleusement
l'un et l'autre leur assurage respectif.
C'est génial.
Je devrais être pas mal, là.
Cette fois-ci, Sébastien
va devoir se mettre plein vide.
Ça va,
pas d'appréhension,
mais il y a de l'ambiance,
il y a de la hauteur,
mais c'est aussi de l'expérience.
C'est le milieu dans lequel on évolue.
On doit s'y habituer
et l'appréhender correctement.
C'est le moment pour nos deux cordistes
de passer à la phase de nettoyage
et, comme des employés
qui font connaissance,
ils parlent de leur vie
en oubliant le vide qui est sous eux.
Tu es originaire d'où ?
Lorraine, et toi ?
Je suis Belge.
Désolé.
Belge d'où ?
Liège.
Tu n'a pas d'accent.
- Ça fait 10 ans que j'habite ici.
L'accent est un peu parti.
Ce n'est pas
tous les jours comme ça,
Ces journées-là font justement
qu'on aime ça, qu'on continue.
Hervé s'est fait opérer
des cervicales
suite à ces nombreux
accidents en montagne.
Après six mois de convalescence,
il est temps d'attaquer sa rééducation.
Là, les cicatrices aux genoux,
celle-ci et celle-là.
J'ai subi six interventions
après cet accident.
Pour sa remise en condition,
un programme précis lui a été prescrit
par les médecins qui l'ont opéré.
Pas question d'être brutal,
les risques de se faire mal sont grands.
Ce n'est pas vraiment un entraînement,
c'est moins intense, mais c'est utile.
Difficile pour un grand sportif
de repartir à zéro dans la mise en forme.
Hervé a une volonté de fer
et il prendra le temps qu'il faut
pour remettre son corps à niveau.
La récupération est fondamentale
pour faire des entraînements plus durs
et faire de belles escalades en montagne.
Il faut encore du temps.
Après sa séance de musculation,
Hervé se dirige maintenant
vers son milieu favori, la montagne.
Pour récupérer,
il faut beaucoup de patience.
On ne peut pas faire ce que l'on veut
du jour au lendemain
parce que le médecin l'a dit.
Hervé doit se rééduquer avec patience.
Il a atteint les plus hauts niveaux
de l'alpinisme mais à un prix.
Aujourd'hui,
il est diminué physiquement,
mais garde sa volonté
de revenir au sommet de sa forme.
Bien, c'est pas mal,
on recommence à se bouger,
donc, tout va très bien.
Il faut un peu de temps.
Avec la neige, tout est beau.
Moi, j'aime l'hiver,
je suis né le 21 décembre.
Hervé rêve de reconquérir les sommets
les plus difficiles de la planète
et, surtout,
de faire partager cette passion.
Un métier qui, pour lui, est le plus beau
même s'il représente
d'énormes risques pour sa propre vie.
Si, un jour, j'avais des enfants,
je serai dans la situation de mon père,
si mon fils me disait :
je veux être alpiniste.
Je pense que je ferais pareil.
Je ne pourrais pas lui refuser,
mais il n'y aurait aucun encouragement.
Ce serait à lui de décider et j'espère
qu'il prendrait la bonne décision.
Gérard et Sébastien
sont deux passionnés de la montagne.
Ils font tous les deux un travail
où la vie ne dépend que d'une corde.
Ils savent
qu'ils n'ont pas le droit à l'erreur
mais, pour rien au monde,
ils ne changeraient.
Ils tracent leur chemin, mettent en place
toute la sécurité qu'ils peuvent
et, surtout, font confiance au destin.